to eastern ukraine now where a top
official says russia is sending more
troops to capture a key city the
governor of the luhansk region says
ukrainian forces are having more trouble
keeping the russians out chris lipsey is
in odessa for us that's a major seaport
where there is a food crisis brewing
chris good morning
[Applause]
good morning tony that's right more than
20 million tons of grain remain blocked
here on ukraine's coast president
zielinski says that mountain could
triple in size by this fall with
russia's invasion now sparking a global
food crisis
wheat fields reduced to battlefields
with those brave enough to work the land
risking their lives so that others can
eat ukraine provides wheat and corn to
some of the neediest countries globally
that's all cut to a trickle by russia's
invasion by land and its blockade by sea
the kremlin is using food supplies
as a stealth missile against developing
countries
the best way to beat it advanced missile
systems like those on route from the
united states to create safe passage for
shipping in the black sea says ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski
ranchi cream creamy i only believe that
as soon as we get these systems it will
be the most powerful guarantee he says
but it's not only russian ships to worry
about it's also mines mostly russian but
ukrainian too there for protection says
captain natalia hemaniac
the danger of a russian amphibious
assault on odessa is still very real she
says russia is also framing ukraine she
says blocking the passage of food
shipments today but with ukrainian minds
russia captured when it annexed crimea
in 2014. as fears mount of a worsening
global food crisis france has urged
finding a so-called off-ramp for
vladimir putin's disastrous war one that
would avoid humiliating the russian
president what do you say to that
it's impossible for putin to humiliate
himself or his country more than he
already has
us secretary of state anthony blinken
has called russia's food blockade
nothing short of blackmail accusing
russia of pilfering the grain and
selling it themselves for their own
profit we've spoken to farmers here on
the ground who say it's not just their
grain that's being stolen it's also
their equipment like tractors nate
chris livesay painting an accurate
picture of war and famine thank you so
much